Rebecca I'm sorry I didn't mean it go
away I'm busy
Rebecca bangers and mash Becca go
ocupado what'd you do that for oh whoa
who's that guy
you
so this is the best friends as a foot
what you're looking for if this tracking
device is riffing
I think it's very friend mine comrade
hey you can't go in there what if I'm
not
they say they're the widget died on
Christmas Eve don't be a punk off
alright you scared listen my friend it's
just one thing my people have taught me
and such there's nothing that can't be
solved by shooting it say I didn't warn
you
don't say I didn't call you an idiot
so I realize I gotta get out of here so
what I did was that uh last night I
looked up to try to find the North Star
but it was cloudy of course so what I
did is that it was not cloudy for like
ten seconds so I got the north side of
this tree and you can see I marked it
with berries here so that way I know
that this way is north and I have one
sheet a scratch paper I have one pan
with just enough ink to get this gone
north send help so if anyone does come
across this way they see that tree
they'll know where I went and they can
at least find well most likely be my
writing course hopefully we won't hear
any more of that for the last time I'm
sorry I thought you were crying or
something no that was after you saw her
can of the can look I feel awful is
there anything I can do to make it up to
you I don't know who breezy Oh
think there's any favors you need cold
in oh I can think of a couple
and now my lovely assistant will show
you that the Hat is empty and that is
how you dispose of a filthy animal who
won't keep his mouth shut okay so in the
Blair Witch Project they come across a
stream and then they just walked right
past it
this was stupid all water leads
somewhere people set up around water cuz
guess what
any water to survive so my thought is
that I just keep an eye out for a stream
listen for some water follow that to
some form of civilization and hopefully
that'll get me some where there's no
water no water at all anywhere why do
you trees get all the trees look at all
the J Poppa no no no water no stream no
anything you see a stream dinner to just
try out the business plan of it turn to
our a kiss or something from dune maybe
even get that I'm referencing to event
oh so I have what I felt was a little
bit of a MacGyver moment I used my hat
and my socks cut it up and I put a rock
in there as well as a means of
collecting rainwater but guess what it's
not doing no rain no rain at all I get
in of it it just seems like the world
uninhabited by water no gods tears today
even I get to here now I'm gonna get
some good
oh we know I got seen my saliva you
Rebecca I really am sorry about all that
stuff I said earlier
yeah we're past that you look really
good in yellow anyways I don't mean my
ass look kind of big but thanks okay
truth or dare
well the truths always got me in trouble
so why stop there truth do you really
think we should stop demo real boy
now that's a toughy I know I always told
Donny that we should but all honesty I
don't know I mean I joined this project
with high hopes and it turned into a
nightmare
I sit in a dark room and throw my soul
down on paper then watch it get torn
apart by whoever Donny the Internet I
guess I'm just lucky to be in a field
where I'm able to express myself but
everybody says it's crap anyway so
what's the point why right if nobody
says you can write why act if nobody
says you can act
my god this is depressing hey no I'm
Irish we have to go put on Angela's
Ashes
just like I remember what's like da da
fuckin ass screw it let's drink oh hey
we're all out hey Mauricio you got any
wine well I wasn't Italian I always come
prepared
oh wow we need a bigger glass
I think Donnie keeps that brandy snifter
in the editing room all right I will go
grab that Oh meantime let's spice things
up a little bit
Fabrizio truth or dare truth have you
ever killed someone dear Rebecca Rebecca
come here go don't protect the booze
you're not gonna believe this
so I rummaged through my pockets and
look what I found
don't based what you would normally
think is a four-course meal but you know
what I'm getting that desperate the only
other thing I found is these uh berries
that I don't know whether or not they're
poisonous the toothpaste has to be safer
right if more than used for brushing is
accidentally swallowed get medical help
or contact a poison control center
you know the poison control center
that's in your local neighborhood who
would've thought that toothpaste was
poisonous google it apparently okay well
I guess now the choice is obvious I
interesting better reading on the back
of that toothpaste label I found out
that the most common thing found in
everybody's bathroom apparently if
consumed too much gives you the shit's
the shakes and cause you to hallucinate
at least that's what the yellow monkey
has been telling me isn't that right
very Winkle
shut up okay I know I'm out of my helmet
that's why I've reached the final act of
desperation after you've drank your own
urine eat leaves and committed possum
side there's only one other desperate
act one can make prayer I'm a worthless
man I'm a small man I just need your
help if you can give me anything some
sign just a little bit of hope for me to
cling on to I will dedicate my life to
making things better not worse and if
not I swear I will sell my soul to Satan
I'll do it I will find the merest
willing critter bludgeon it to death and
sacrifice it on a black altar of pine
cones and tree sap nothing nada okay
hey seen it's Donny um I know we haven't
talked much before but uh if you could
just send me a woodland critter and
maybe some pine cones and some tree sap
well that was a bust but hey I'm the
plus a at least I know now going around
in the
I realized something now life is not a
movie you can try your best do
everything correct and yet you can still
fail just get used to it it's the way
things are gonna happen because you can
try your best to do everything right but
in the end you still wake up in the
middle of the forest abandoned undying
to death nothing is going to save me
right now I'm just gonna die alone I
don't know how my mom used to love this
stuff I don't know how she carried that
enthusiasm how she used to have so much
brightness Doron and then how did it get
her through such tough times how did
that carry her how can I get just a
little bit of that right now just a
little bit to get me through this pain
the answer is I can't
nobody can so just give up yeah this
looks like a good place to die
man don't worry I'm coming soon
Oh
miles Haley
humming focused
kinematic refers lock detector down
repeats director down
Oh